فماذا لو قلنا هذا الصباح ان 8% من حمض
النووي يتكون من بقايا فيروسات قديمه
بالاكثر من ذلك ماذا لو قلنا ان 40% من
جناتنا لها اصل فيروس سي وكل ذلك يجعل من
مجال بكتيريا الامعاء مفتاحا للشفاء من
الفداء ودواء مايكروبات الامعاء لها عدد
من الوظائف مثل الهضم تعزيز المناعه حمايه
الجسم من الكائنات الدقيقه المسببه
للامراض هذا معروف والمعروض ايضا منذ عقد
من الزمان انا التغيرات الميكروبيه هي عام
الاساسيه وراء العديد من امراض المناعه
الذاتيه مثل السكر من النوع الاول ومرته
لنبسط الموضوع لكم يعمل العلماء اليوم على
توجيه الميكروبات الموجوده في الامعاء
لعلاج الامراض المناعه الذاتيه اه
والامراض المزمنه ماذا يعني ذلك يعني انا
قد نشهد نهايه مرض خطير مثل الزهايمر به
حبوب تحفز نمو البكتيريا المفيده لنبدا
اولا لعلاقه كل ذلك
اي معاكي لميس
سشري اختبارات الحمض النووي الاختبارات
الجينيه لاكثر من سبب منها الكشف الاستباق
عن طفرات المحتمله في الجينات التي يمكن
ان تتسبب في اضطراب الماء مثل السرطان
وغيره ويخضع لها الاشخاص اذا كانت اسرهم
لديها تاريخ من الاصابه بمرضيثي
يمكن ان تظهر اختبارات الحمض النووي ايضا
لاصول العرقيه للاشخاص والمنطقه الجغرافيه
التي تعود لها سفرتهم الوراثيه ورص سلسله
النسب والاسلاف الفحوص السابقه للولاده قد
تكشف بعض انواع الترابات في جينات الجنين
مثل متلازمه داون ويتم عن طريق اخذ عينه
الدم من الام فحص المواليد هو واحد من
الاختبارات الاكثر شيوعا في الولايات
المتحده ويخضع له الطفل تحسبا بوجود بعض
الاضطرابات الجينيه مثل قصور الغده
الدرقيه وحينها تتم رعايته وبدء علاجها
على الفور جمع عينه الحمض النووي تتم من
خلال اللعاب او مسح الجزء الداخلي من
الخلف ثم توضع تلك المسحه في وعاء نظيف
لكن بعض الحالات تستوجب سحب الدم ايضا
ويمكن الاعتماد على عينات من الاظافر
والشعر
[موسيقى]
على كل طبيبه وعلمه الجينات ورئيس جمعيه
الامراض المتوارثه جنيا في الامارات
الدكتوره مريم الدكتوره يسعد صباحك نورتنا
في الاستديو اهلا بك طيب دكتوره بحسب
دراسه تحاليل الحمض النووي تمثل فقط واحد
في المئه فقط من تاريخنا لكن توضح لنا
اكثر واحنا كنا نعول على الدي ان اي
والجنات
التكنولوجيا صارت عندنا امك كانت موجوده
احنا نكتشف الاجزاء الثانيه من جسم
الانسان اليوم عرفنا انه معانا كائنات
عايشه في جسمها اسمها المايكروبايه من
الميكروبايه وهي البيئه اللي تعيش فيه
الكائنات الدقيقه
قدرنا ما في داعي نحن نزرع هذه الكائنات
الدقيقه
بس انها عالم اخر على سبيل المثال احنا
الكناس كان انسان كائن انساني عندنا
تقريبا 20,000 جنيه لما جمعوا هاي
البكتيريا تقريبا 49 مليون جينه موجوده في
عينه واحده اللي تمثل الفم
والقولون العصبي
همم القولون فبالتالي اليوم عرفنا انه مش
فقط احنا موجودين كثير ايه وفي تعليمات
لكلامك مزاجك والاجمل من ذلك في اخر دراسه
سووها تجمع والناس اللي تم همم تشخيص
بامراض معينه وخاصه امراض السائده في
العصر الضغط والسكر السمنه خذوا عينات من
كل مجموعه من هذه الناس وقدرنا نعرف ان في
كائنات معينه بكتيريا اخذوا هذه البكتيريا
وزرعوها في فئران التجارب اللي ما فيها اي
عله فقط عقب سته اسابيع تفاجا او ان الفار
اللي اعطوني البكتيريا اللي موجوده عند
الشخص اللي عند ارتفاع صدقت صار عندي
الضغط الشخص اللي كان عنده سمنه الفار بدا
يسمن الشخص اللي كان عند القولون العصبي
الفار صار عندي قانون العصب الشخص اللي
كان عندك اكتئاب الفار بدات تطلع عند
اعراض الدكتوره مريم طالما انه كان في
اصلا يعني عدم الوصول لفك الشفره الجينيه
خصوصا في السنين الاخيره اللي بتتعلق بجسم
الانسان هل يعني انه عدنا للمربع الاول في
الدراسات المتعلقه في الجينات لانه كان
قبل يتم دراسه الامراض وخصوصا الامراض
المتناقله عبر الاجيال من خلال الدي ان
ايه اليوم دخلنا بقصه الامعاء دقيقه هل
سندمج الدراستان مع بعض كيف سنحل المساله
المربع الاول ولكن وصلنا للمربع العشره
اليوم فصلنا المربعانيه فبالتالي هو
بروجريس يعني هو تطور لفهم وادراك مكونات
جسم الانسان الاهم من ذلك ان احنا كنا ناس
مختصرين في هذا الجانب شو اهتمامنا ليش
اني انا اعرف دي الكائنات الدقيقه احنا كل
ما نسعى ان احنا نرفع جوده صحه الانسان
فبالتالي اليوم حصلنا علاقه واضحه بين
امراض معينه لازم نعالجها فقط بالادويه
عرفنا لها بدائل اخرى نفس الادراك اللي
انا مع علم فوق الجينات قبل ما كنا نعرف
ان العوامل البيئيه تلعب دور مباشر في
تحفيز الجينات الموروثه عنا وهذه عطانا
نوع من الوضوح الاكثر كنا نعمل فحص جينيه
كامله للشخص يطلع عندي قابليه للسرطان
الثدي ولكن نشوف ما صار عنده سرطان الثدي
يعرفنا ان اليوم هاي البكتيريا النافعه او
الكائنات الدقيقه في الامعاء تلعب دور
كبير في صحتنا
اكتشفته بهذه الدراسه هناك ترابط كبير بين
الكائنات الدقيقه وامراض المزمنه كلنا
نرجعها للوراثه وعلم الوراثه كالضغط
والسكري وامراض القلب هل يمكن معالجه هذه
الامراض هذه المره من دون دواء على اساس
وراثي ولكن استهداف هذه الكائنات
وايد مهم نحط فيه بالنا ان اي علاج جديد
ما نقدر نعمل مع الكل لازم يكون في دراسات
سريريه
اكيد ونقدر نعتمد نوع البكتيريا كميه
البكتيريا اليوم احنا قاعدين نشارك
المجتمع بهذا ليش عشان اليوم انا كان
انسانه اقدر ابادر في وقايه نفسي حتى قبل
ما يطلع العلاج بطرق بسيطه اعرف ان اليوم
عايشين معي نعتبرهم ضيوف انت يوم عندك
ضيوف في البيت حتى لو انت بجيتارين توفري
لهم همم الاكل اللي فيه لحم فبالتالي
بناخذ بالنا منها الضيوف الموجودين
هالضيوف وايد يحبون الالياف الالياف اللي
موجوده في الخضروات موجوده في العدس شويه
نقوم بالواجب معه ضيوفنا واحنا كعرب
معروفين بكرامنا وشفنا الكرم العراقي
البكتيريا تحب الالياف هذه البكتيريا تحب
الانسان ينام من وقت عشان واحنا نايمين
بالليل لما ناكل وجبات العشاء قبل الساعه
10:00 نعطيها فتره كافيه في الليل تجدد
نفسها تزيد طبقه المخاطيه نراعيها يعني
اليوم اخذنا الكثير من الادويه في ناس
يقولون انا دكتوره ليش اخذ المكملات
الغذاء الغذائيه اكلي فيه كافي اليوم
عرفنا ان هذه الكائنات الدقيقه مش فقط
تساعدنا في هضم الاكل ولكن كذلك تصنع
انواع معينه من المواد الكيميائيه المهمه
جدا بمزاجنا على سبيل المثال سامحيني سيره
تنين معروف انه واحد من المواصلات العصبيه
اللي تخلي الانسان يعيش بالرضا والسعاده
80% من هذه الماده هاي الكائنات الدقيقه
تعملها اذا كان عندنا نقص في هذا النوع من
الكائنات الدقيقه اللي تصنعنها هذا
فبالتالي بشكل مباشر ياثر على المزاجنا
والعكس صحيح كلامك دكتوره مريم عمليه انا
كشخص هلا اذا كان عندي فضول بدي اعمل لفحص
الدي ان ايه واعرف انا تاريخ تسلسل الجيني
ومن اين اصولي هل اليوم استطيع مباشره ان
اقوم بعمل فحص من خلال الامعاء البكتيريا
الدقيقه موجوده لدي لكي اعرف الامراض اللي
ممكن ان تحصل لي في المستقبل او اتجنبها
احلفي مركز الشيخ زايد للابحاث الجينيه
كانت لنا الرياده ان احنا نجمع الفحص
الجني الخلايا الانسانيه مع الفحص الجيني
للكائنات الدقيقه واعطتني صوره واضحه لصحه
الانسان الحين اضافه قابليتك للاصابه
المعينه بالامراض التي تتعلمين الرقص ولا
لا نتقابليه ان نوع الرياضه يعني اليوم
حتى اصول لك بنقول لك قصه الرقصه الثانيه
ياخذ هذه المهاره اسرع من غيره فبالتالي
لما ياخذ الكورسات
للمثال عقب ما نعرف اصورك الجنيه نقول لك
بالضبط اذا انت ناويه تخسري وزن في اوقات
معينه تعملين فيها رياضه اذا تريدين
تكتسبين عضل في اوقات معينه تلعبي فيها
رياضه العلم جميل تطور بشكل عجيب ولكن كل
اللي احنا لازم نسويه نتثقف اكثر وناخذه
من مصادر الصحيحه
شكرا
في الراس راح تصير تقول جيناتي
هههه الجينات ورئيس جمعيه الامراض
المتوارثه جينيا في الامارات الدكتوره
مريم مطر نورتينا شكرا دكتور